It literally hit me the other day
that my daughter is going to be dating boys soon.
No, not too soon.
She's turning 10 this year.
But, like,
we are. We are really just a hop,
skip, and a jump from puberty,
and that's when all of the shit goes down.
So I realized that I put a lot of, like,
dating and relationship advice out there,
and there's a chance that she will take absolutely none of it,
because that's what kids do.
Kids have to learn the lessons their own way.
And the last person they're gonna take advice from
when they think they know everything is their parent.
Right.
And I always talk on here about how lucky I am to have met my husband,
how great our marriage is,
and how much, like,
we love and like each other.
I realized I had to go through a lot of bullshit before I got there,
and she's about to have to go through all the bullshit,
and I really don't want that for her.
It's part of the deal, but I don't want it for her.
Like, I'm gonna have to listen to her cry about some Chad
who wants to play video games more than take her out on a date.
And have to tow the line
where you're not talking trash about the boyfriend
because the boyfriend might come back.
I know that the next chapter of parenting is coming,
and I'm not sure I'm quite prepared for that,
because I'm very opinionated.
In some ways, babies are easier